la primavera ha llegado y con ella las
expectativas de una contraofensiva
todo el mundo espera ir a liberar
nuestro territorio Y eso es lo que
mantiene el ánimo la esperanza de que
pronto iremos por ello
los planes son de alto secreto pero es
probable que el primer objetivo sea
melitópol la mayor ciudad ocupada en la
región de saporilla
si tomamos meritopol podemos tomar
maripol y verdiáns Y entonces les
habremos aislado de crimea la parte
ocupada de la región de gersón estará
rodeada y no tendrán opciones tendremos
un camino abierto hacia crimea
hace poco más de un año se detuvo la
ofensiva rusa en la región de saporilla
en las afueras pero desde entonces los
bombardeos no han cesado esta escuela
fue bombardeada hace dos semanas Aunque
hacía tiempo que todos los niños de
origen habían sido evacuados los adultos
que quedan pasan gran parte de su tiempo
en el sótano de esta otra escuela ahora
un centro de acogida que ofrece comida
duchas y electricidad en las últimas 24
horas los ocupantes dispararon sobre la
región de saporilla más de 100 veces lo
digo todos los días pero no en las
noticias sino con mis propios oídos
trabajamos hasta las 5 y media porque
aquí el toque de queda empieza a las 6 y
luego nos montamos en las motos
bombardean y volvemos a casa todos los
días igual
Nos gustaría que las cosas fueran más
rápido estamos un poco cansados de esto
estaría bien que al menos los hicieran
retroceder un poco que nos dieran un
respiro
todas estas personas decidieron no
marcharse hace tiempo así que esperan el
próximo movimiento de Ucrania